hi there steve kaufman here
[Music]
and to talk about language learning to
talk about language learning books
uh please again subscribe if you enjoy
these videos uh
you can click on the little bell to get
notifications and please also join me at
link which is where i do most of my
language learning before i jump into the
subject of books i just want to quickly
review my statistics you'll see that uh
my sort of
new words or known words added is a
little below my average
uh
inevitably we're going to have periods
where we're a little bit less motivated
that's why i did the video about variety
it's important to vary your activities
because after a while doing the same
thing over and over again
yes sort of your motivation starts to
flag so if you look at my statistics
you'll see i'm this is probably has been
my slowest week the other thing is that
the weather has been good the weather is
good again today so i'm going golfing
with my wife
and i mean the activity of language
learning has to be enjoyable so
you don't want to push
when you're really not that motivated
or sometimes you do push to try to get
into it and once you get into it you're
happy that you're there like getting
into a very very hot bathtub
or a very cold
swim for example at any rate books okay
so one of the things that happens when i
learn a language is i get interested in
the history and the culture that
surrounds that language
and so i like
you know exploring different aspects of
the history so i found this book
and it's a history of cairo it's very
interesting it sort of tells the story
of this
city
tracing it back to the ancient egyptians
to the period when the greeks were there
and the romans were there and then
various you know um caliphate out of
damascus and then
the fatimids who came in from tunis
tunisia and who were shia and there was
a great flowering of culture and science
and tolerance of christians and jews you
know christians were dominant i think up
until
uh at least up until the period of the
fatimids the coptic the original uh
christians of egypt and then of course
the mamalux came in and they
re-established sunni is the dominant
religion they were less
tolerant
and then you had this period of the
ottoman empire and then you had
this albanian interlude with
i can't remember muhammad ali maybe
mustafa ali i can't remember anyway and
then then you had the uh
you know napoleon and increasing uh sort
of colonials type pressures from
european countries
uh
sort of a
call it a flowering at a very top level
for
uh you know italians and french and
brits and people within cairo society
who
kind of
uh
interact with them and that's about as
far as i've come but it's an interesting
story it's a collection of stories now
imagine that this were available in
arabic
uh a series of
20-minute
stories different sort of
vignettes of people in
cairo over the centuries
with audio
i mean if it's just a book than with the
glossary but with an extensive glossary
or ideally we bring it into link we have
the audio we can look words up that
would be i mean if this whole book were
converted into arabic stories that would
keep me busy for months and it would be
fascinating for me
now
i'm a sucker for books so when i look
for books around arabic on the internet
on amazon a number of things obviously
get suggested to me and i end up buying
them so i bought a thing called you know
modern arabic short stories
the problem is that they don't have
really any kind of glossary they just
have a translation which is very
inconvenient to work with
so i haven't gotten into it yet i am
hoping that when my arabic gets good
enough that i can read without being
assisted by by my ipad by being able to
look words up or hear the text to speech
or do all the other things that we do at
length to be able to look at each
sentence with the natural voice and and
and when i really can hit a book then
i'll be reading this but for the time
being no
uh one of my earlier investments was in
uh of course asimil
which is somewhere here but uh here we
are yeah i got so many of these so
asimil it's okay but it's the same few
voices every every lesson and the
lessons the content is a little silly
after a while i i didn't really find
this all that great
and it's quite expensive for what you
get
on the subject of stories i've also
bought this the travels of ibn batuta
very famous i believe moroccan
who traveled the known world at that
time
again unfortunately as in many of these
books that they do at universities
they want to fill it with a lot of
comprehension questions
and uh other exercises to turn it into
more of a project for them
all i would really want is the text with
audio so that's again something i'll be
looking forward to when i'm better
here again i've bought modern arabic
short stories
always in the hope that i'll get audio
and there is no audio but this is at
least bilingual but bilingual is also
awkward because you're having to switch
back and forth from one language to
another
and i prefer
glossaries
or
the way we do it of course at link
then here's a thing called focus on
contemporary arabic with online media
okay now the problem with this
uh and the sort of companion piece
this is all from shukri abed spoken
uh standard arabic
so there we do have glossaries but again
lots of
exercises but the problem is the
accompanying
media is dvd
dvd means i got to sit there and watch
it i don't want to sit there and watch
it i want to take away take it away and
listen to it more of the same however
again these are things that when i'm
more comfortable reading away from the
computer i will get at those
um
so then what else did i get myself media
arabic media arabic again you get into
it
and it's full of all kinds of advice on
how to read critically make sure you
evaluate the sources and what they're
saying and all of these
uh
you know
teaching of critical thinking which i
consider to be
a fad basically when you read you should
be able to evaluate the text as well as
their sources what are facts and what
are opinions in the news you are reading
this is supposed to be teaching language
first of all i don't believe you can
teach critical thinking i think the
ability to think critically is based on
your knowledge if you know a lot about a
subject you are able to evaluate it and
you can think critically if you don't
know very much
there is no sort of theory of teaching
critically theory of making sure you
evaluate the sources
knowledge leads to critical evaluation
so
nevertheless
uh i will
have another look at this but again the
font is so small you know arabic is
difficult for the beginner like me to
read
so um
yeah and of course the other problem but
i'm a sucker so i buy these things uh
advanced media arabic
again the problem is this one has nice
font by the way this one has really nice
font but has lots of drills and
exercises and translations and stuff and
the other problem is media arabic means
that they are taking
articles from the bbc from fros vancat
from al jazeera that are five years old
well i can get up-to-date articles from
those news sources and i can study them
looking at words
uh because it's online
so really what do they provide here not
very much a very small glossary for each
uh for each of these but but it does
have the advantage that i have them
written out and for me to read them in
text in a book as opposed to reading
them online introduces an element of
variety so i don't think it's a great
investment but
it's part of my investment in
introducing some variety in what i'm
doing
uh you know i did buy this here
mastering arabic
again from hippocrene not very good lots
of drills
uh very difficult to read font
um but
it's something there that when i get
tired of what i'm doing i can go in and
have a look but again it doesn't cover
much
ground the other thing of course is
we need so much content we need so much
content because
after we get past the sort of original
stage
the word frequency declines very quickly
so we have to be covering so much
content so much content there are books
that anyway i won't go through them all
sometimes i don't mind looking at sort
of lists of vocabulary this book is
quite good
for different sort of subject areas
again in the eye in the sense of of
doing things that are a little different
so that you introduce variety into what
you are doing however for me
the the best would be sort of a history
of
a history of the levant there's so much
history there
iraq syria lebanon
uh egypt the north africa the barbary
coast all this kind of stuff give us the
history in
digestible morsels or
simply hist story of people
or modern short stories audio and text
25 starting with five minutes long 15
minutes on audio that's what i would
like to see with far fewer drills
comprehension questions and all this
other stuff
teaching you how to think critically
uh and uh oh and i should say that on a
number of them georgetown university in
particular they promise you audio and
you go there and there's no audio so you
have a sense that these very expensive
textbooks produced by
universities add very little are quite
disorganized and misleading in terms of
what they offer the people who buy these
expensive books
however i remain a sucker for books
i like covering the same ground
in different ways i try you know i get
in there i try to read these but it's
too early for me because i'm just not
good enough at reading arabic however
study of arabic the study of the arab
world it's going to be with me for a
long time so i'm in no great hurry
actually i'm just enjoying you know
immersing myself in things arabic
and of course at the end of my 90-day
challenge i'll swing back to persian and
i've already bought some books
on persian history
in english
plus i have my
history of iran in persian prepared by
sahara in iran which is on link so i'll
just continue to wallow in all this
stuff and enjoy myself so that's what i
wanted to say a bit of a ramble on
language learning books bye for now
[Music]
you